PHIL MORIARTY: Right I've got
my trusty guitar on my back.
Last few months I've been
working on a special musical
collaboration related to a very
important number in nature.
We're about to head off down
the road to meet this
collaborator for the very
first time, and I'm very
excited about it.
We're at the studio of Mr.
Dave Brown, here--
DAVE BROWN: Hi!
PHIL MORIARTY: Yes, with his
trademark "hi," who's a very
talented musician, producer.
So we're writing a song, a math
metal song about phi.
Math metal's a genre which
is very sort of
mathematically-based
riffs, I guess.
Very, very syncopated,
very technical.
And after we filmed a video on
pi for Numberphile, a few
months, Dave got in touch and
was keen to collaborate and to
really take that idea
and push it further.
And so what we've done is we've
based a song around to
the number phi, based the
rhythms, based the melody-- if
you can call it that--
based the lyrics, all around
phi, the number phi.
DAVE BROWN: First riff I've
got in the song--
it's a nice clean one.
[MUSIC PLAYS]
DAVE BROWN: Before we punch
you in the face.
And that's derived from a
riff Phil came up with--
as you can see here, quite
conveniently--
from the different
digits of phi.
PHIL MORIARTY: What we also want
to do as well as mapping
the digits of phi on to the
melodies, on to the riffs, and
on to the rhythms, is also
somehow embed the geometry of
phi in the song.
And the way we're gonna do that
is we're going to take
the guitar string, length of the
guitar string, and we're
going to pick out the note which
defines, or the position
on the string which defines the
golden ratio, the note of
the golden ratio, as it were.
And so what we're doing is--
this is a guitar string,
from here to here.
The fundamental definition
of the golden ratio
is you've got AB.
So you've got a length A and
you've got a length B here.
So A plus B over A is equal
to A over B, and
that's equal to phi.
What we're going to do now is
use your wonderful golden
ratio calipers--
where have they gone--
to define where that note is.
It's going to be a note that's
not going to match up exactly
with to where-- though
it's not too far--
where we have a fret
on the guitar.
It's just slightly below
the 17th fret.
And then what we're going to do
is we're going to overdub
on top of that, or maybe build
it up-- we'll see.
As Dave suggested, what
we're going to do is
then build this up.
So we'll go from that, just
below the 17th fret.
Then we're going to choose
another note, which as you can
see is just around about where
the screws in the pickup are.
And then we're going to
subdivide that down again,
each time building up and each
time defining the note of the
golden ratio geometrically.
DAVE BROWN: OK.
So this next riff, I thought
it'd be quite cool if we took
the number of chugs that a
guitar plays-- technical term,
a chug is when the guitar
goes chnnh.
Sounds like-- it's
onomatopoeic.
And we took a number of
them and put a gap in
between each one.
And if you count the number of
chugs between each gap, you
actually get the number phi,
which is quite cool.
So take a listen.
[RIFF PLAYS]
So there was one chug, six
chugs, one chug, eight--
yeah, you get the idea.
PHIL MORIARTY: So these are
gold nanoparticles, two
nanometers across, in water.
We're not going to really
use the nanoparticles.
What we are going to use
is the vial that the
nanoparticles are in.
But of course, it's gold.
It's the golden ratio, so
we thought it was apt.
Well, I thought it was apt.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVE BROWN: Next up, we get to a
riff that's kind of like the
pi video that you guys did,
where Phil mapped the digits
of pi onto a scale.
We did that with phi onto the
B-flat harmonic minor scale.
I'm not really good
at musical tech.
I do it by ear.
Could I get him shouting
into the mic?
I need to get a level,
unfortunately.
I'll give you some volume
so you can do it, but.
PHIL MORIARTY: [SHOUTS]
DAVE BROWN: (SHOUTING)
Real but uncountable!
PHIL MORIARTY: I've done
this for a long, long
time, over 20 years.
So I was in a band while
I was a student.
While I was a post-graduate
as well.
(SHOUTING) Irrational.
DAVE BROWN: I did
A-level maths.
I got a C. I blame my teacher.
I'm more of a musician now.
I have a YouTube channel
called Boy in a Band.
You can search for that.
It'll probably be in
the description.
I'll make sure Brady
puts it there.
BRADY: I will even put it--
it'll be just on this--
just there.
DAVE BROWN: Oh, there we go.
How about that?
BRADY: Cool.
DAVE BROWN: But, yes.
I make music of varying
styles.
Lots of electronic music,
but I'm horrendously
into metal as well.
I just used horrendously
twice.
I hope that's OK.
(SHOUTING) Emerge from
the equation!
Spirals out of control!
PHIL MORIARTY: One, six, one
eight, oh, three, three, nine,
eight, eight, seven, four--
It's been a hell of
a lot of fun.
And I'm really happy
with the song.
I think we've done some very
interesting things.
We've gone beyond--
people talk about math metal,
but math metal, those riffs
sound complicated, but they're
not really mapped onto maths.
In this case, we've actually
gone beyond that.
And there's only one other
band, to the best of my
knowledge, that has attempted
anything like this before, and
that's a band called
After the Burial.
(SINGING) The proportion
is divine.
DAVE BROWN: So phi is 1 plus the
square root of 5 over 2.
So we decided to be a bit
clever, and we have got 1 in
this by the open string on the
guitar, representing that.
And the other notes being played
by the guitar are the
digits of square root of 5.
And then over 2, we go into
half-time drums partway
through this, which I thought
was quite clever, so.
[METAL MUSIC PLAYING]
BRADY: That's quite
clever, isn't it?
DAVE BROWN: Yeah.
BRADY: You pleased with it?
PHIL MORIARTY: Some
people might
not consider it beautiful.
I think the way that the maths
are embedded throughout the
song, yeah, has its own
bizarre beauty about.
Yes.
[MUSIC  PLAYING]
DAVE BROWN: And we do
a similar thing for
the outro as well.
[RIFF PLAYS]
The 1 there is that [HUM]
top note.
Then we've got the chugs.
You remember what chugs are?
Doing square root of 5.
And again, half-time drums.
PHIL MORIARTY: Leibniz was a
very famous mathematician,
developed calculus independently
of Newton.
And he has this wonderful quote,
which is that music is
the human mind counting
when it doesn't
know that it's counting.
And that's great.
There are these fundamental
links between numbers, between
maths, to music.
And it's great to actually embed
those so tightly as we
do in this song.
BRADY: Well hopefully, by now,
you're all dying to hear the
finished song.
I know I am.
I haven't actually got the
final copy from Dave yet.
We're going to upload
it here on the
Numberphile channel on Friday.
If you're watching this video
after Friday, I'll have the
link below the video,
and you'll be able
to find it, of course.
Also below the video in the
description, I'll have a link
to Dave's channel.
You really should
check it out.
He's a super-talented guy.
And I'll also have some
information under the video
about these golden mean
calipers, which were sent to
us from New Zealand.
They're lots of fun, and I'm
sure you're all going to have
some questions about them.
And we'll be using them in some
future videos we've got
coming about the golden ratio
on Numberphile in the weeks
and months to come.
But for now, we'll hear
the song on Friday.
[MUSIC PLAYING]